well ladies and gentlemen we got him the
IRS has released Donald Trump's tax
returns in fact six years worth of tax
returns to the house committee that is
involved in that investigation it has
taken three years but it has finally
happened and now this becomes a matter
of watching for leaks and of course I
would never tell anyone to leak anything
or to disclose sensitive information or
to do anything wrong I would just never
do that but I also understand from an
objective standpoint that the
possibility of a leak here is
significant and we are going to be
watching for that CNBC reports IRS gives
Trump tax returns to house committee
after three-year legal battle the final
straw was the Supreme Court saying we're
not going to block the release of these
tax returns the article points out the
house Ways and Means Committee has
obtained years worth of federal income
tax returns for former president Donald
Trump just a week after the Supreme
Court rejected his effort to block that
democratic-controlled panel from getting
those records from the IRS the committee
has been seek had been seeking Trump's
tax return since 2019 when he was still
president Trump broke Decades of
tradition by refusing to publicly
release his tax returns now remember
that for a very long time Trump was
insisting as soon as my audits are done
and
I'm going to go ahead and release
everything and the goal posts kept
moving and moving and moving here's just
a little bit of a reminder of that this
is more recent he says you just said you
spoke to your accountant about
potentially releasing your taxes did he
tell you when you can release them do
you how big is the order deadline for
when you're going to release it I get
married worse than the Tea Party got
treated because I have a lot of people
in there deep down in the IRS they treat
me horribly we made a deal it was all
settled until I decide to run for
president
I get treated very badly by the IRS very
unfairly but we had a deal all done as
soon as we're completed with the deal I
want to release it but says you just
said you spoke yeah uh he didn't really
intend to release those tax returns and
quite frankly once it became clear that
his followers didn't really care I
understand why he didn't release them
and we'll get in a moment to what we
believe would be in there a few other
notes here from the CNBC
um report a treasury Department
spokesperson told NBC News quote
treasury has complied with last week's
Court decision the treasury Department
is the parent of the IRS the Ways and
Means Committee has said it wanted
copies of Trump's tax returns and the
tax returns of trump legal entities for
an inquiry into how the IRS audits
presidential tax returns by law the tax
agency audits the returns of a sitting
president every year so it's a leak
watch now what is most likely in those
town tax returns I we've been building
and sort of tweaking our belief about
this based on what has become publicly
available information over time I think
the most likely Revelations from Trump's
taxes would all be things that we
suspect or to some degree know already
number one Trump is not as rich as he
claims to be
it's hard to imagine Trump being richer
than he claims to be and based on what
people like Michael Cohen and others
have told us Donald Trump has postured
to be higher on the Forbes richest list
using all sorts of different methods and
more than likely his taxes would show
he's not actually as rich as he has
claimed to be number two Trump lies and
that we know we know Trump lies he's the
most dishonest president in the modern
political era number three Trump
probably has debts that we might call
sketchier debts shadier debts to
entities or individuals that he likely
would not want us to know and which may
potentially present a national security
risk even greater than that which we
already believe based on publicly
available information and I think that
that would be the those would be the
main Revelations from Donald Trump's tax
returns now one interesting other note I
want to mention Donald Trump as you know
exhausted just about every he exhausted
did every means available to him to try
to block the release of these tax
returns including going to the Supreme
Court and It ultimately did not work now
we can colloquially say
would someone who has nothing to hide
work this hard to hide their tax returns
well I don't know a lot of it could just
be ego Trump doesn't want the world to
know beyond any doubt that he's not as
rich as he claims to be but one of the
arguments that through his lawyers
Donald Trump made to the Supreme Court
was that no Congress has ever wielded
its legislative powers to demand a
president's tax returns and that
continues to be a theme this has no
president has ever had his home raided
by the FBI Trump said that after the
search warrant was executed in
Mar-A-Lago these things haven't happened
before because we've never needed to see
them happen before Donald Trump Donald
Trump so flouted the Norms of the
presidency that when you get
unprecedented inputs you end up with
unprecedented outputs outputs and it's
really that simple
um do Republicans even care I don't
think so I don't know that they ever
really cared if they care shared they
might not have voted for Donald Trump to
begin with when he didn't release his
tax returns and made it clear he didn't
really plan to and the audit story was
completely made up so the house Ways and
Means Committee has Trump's taxes six
years worth we now will wait very
patiently to see out of genuine
curiosity whether those tax returns leak
we're going to take a very quick break
and be back right after this I love
reading I read every day no matter how I
arrange my schedule I never have enough
time to read all the books that I want
which is why blinkist has been such an
important part of my life for years now
our sponsor blinkist is the app that
takes thousands of non-fiction books
boils them down into an explainer that
you can read or listen to in just 15
minutes which includes all the most
important takeaways from the book with
blinkist I can absorb the essence of 15
different books in an afternoon so so I
can quickly gather insights from all
sorts of perspectives make connections
have those kind of aha moments that
don't happen so easily which is why I
feel enriched when I use blinkist
blinkist also summarizes episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers and with the blinkist connect
feature my girlfriend and I can share
one account share books podcasts with
each other talk about them on the go and
don't forget blinkus makes the perfect
holiday gift my audience can try
blinkist free for seven days and get 25
percent off after that go to
blinkist.com Pacman the link is down
below